[Music]
LeBron's moved to Los Angeles and the
Lakers has more to do with Hollywood
than basketball the 33 year old got his
first taste of Hollywood in 2008 when he
executive produced the documentary about
his high school basketball career
that same year LeBron became the first
african-american man and NBA player to
land the cover of Vogue posing with
Gisele Bundchen in 2009 he made his TV
debut playing himself on an episode of
Entourage they have a million fans in
2011 King James created an animated
youtube series called the LeBrons try to
do things a lot of people who don't want
to do or a world tribe but shortly after
that interview LeBron took a break from
Hollywood to focus on winning his first
NBA championship but once he collected
back-to-back titles with the Miami Heat
he turned his attention to the big
screen scoring a scene-stealing role in
Amy Schumer's 2015 movie trainwreck you
know Superman was created in Cleveland
yeah no I know Superman was creating
Cleveland you've told me that I was kind
of nervous I've never done nothing like
this ignoring those nerves LeBron
doubled down on his Hollywood dreams
starting a production company Spring
Hill entertainment and signing a deal
with Warner Brothers he currently has
nearly a dozen projects in the works
including the game show hit the wall and
he's gained four more acting - he'll
produce and star in the sequel to
Michael Jordan's 1996 classic space jam
and this September his animated movie
small foot hits theaters now you gotta
live life to the fullest cuz you want to
get one crack
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]